hey guys how's it going today we're
going to make some bb-8 cocktails now
this was actually submitted by one of
you guys and I was looking and trying to
find out where this image originated
from it's from some bar in Tokyo if I'm
wrong please correct me in the comments
because I definitely want to find this
place and go to it for the time being
I'm going to try to recreate it and see
what happens and I hope it works first
things you're going to need is some
glasses some lemonade and I already did
this but I made some little molds for BB
head out of lemonade and I just got this
on Amazon I'll put a link in the
description where you guys can check it
out this is actually meant to make molds
that are little circles or spheres but I
use half of it to make the top of bb-8's
head we're also going to need some ice
we're also going to need some oranges go
you are the blueberries still in here
frozen berries feel like I want some ice
but I want to crush the ice so I'm going
to put it in a Ziploc bag and hit it
with something ow I cut myself on an ice
cube that's
sucks
FU oh
boy okay it's
cool all right uh
so these look good this looks like it
might actually work step one God there's
ice cubes everywhere and this is going
to be bb-8's little
body now from the image it looks like
these are cut very thin so I'm going to
try to cut that this as thin as I can
without screwing it up that actually
looks perfect I could not have done it
more perfect even if I tried harder than
I already did yeah well that one I could
have tried a little harder I'm trying to
focus so hard so I don't cut myself I do
not want to go to the
hospital we're going to start with
our glasses like so
so we have one of these down below put
some ice in put maybe one of these over
to the side like
[Music]
so look at this can you
even some more these ice cubes on De the
blueberries need to be prepped we're
going to stick it on as bb-8's little
eyeball
should I cut it this
way this is going to be so
[Music]
perfect
so settle
yourself oh
God I need need a whole new kitchen
after this Extravaganza so I need to
make a nice surface put the bb-8 head on
pop out our bb-8 head he doesn't quite
look the right
size but this is all made of lemonade so
here we go bb-8 head a little eye right
there another one right there it looks
great it looks just okay definitely not
my best work definitely not my worst
work though let's be real here we go
I don't know what that is there you go
little guy you look very cute I probably
recommend getting like coffee stirs and
putting them in here instead of like a a
straw but this could work and then what
I'm going to do is I'm going to cut this
I'll cut
one bb-8 is falling
apart I think the white looks better
actually all right guys come try your
drinks Jenna this one's for you thank
you but I'm not even on the camera
camera scoot it over oh I'm spilling it
everywhere oh it has a smiley
face well it tastes like lemonade to me
yeah what is this thing um it's a
lemonade ice cube I like this look
lemonade ice cube is cute can I have
another one cuz I'm going to pound this
in like 10 seconds yeah I'll make you
another one but I'm not cutting any more
oranges it's got to be the BB drink
though you can't cut Corners you can
have some of mine we're cutting Corners
all right guys thank you so much for
watching hope you enjoyed this video let
me know in the comments below what you'd
like me to make next or I'll attempt to
make it no promises because clearly some
things haven't gone well cheers thank
you it's very good I'm very impressed
thank you do you want to see what the
picture look like yeah that's pretty
close you did a good job oh there ice
cube everywhere but why did you wait
what why does he have two big
blueberries like he's got I didn't have
any smaller blueberries that was all I
could I don't know bye guys thanks for
watching peace it is really nicely made
and it looks good oh you look good open
this up this here too